- My kids won't even know what a TV is.
- And when they do see a TV,
they'll be like, "What do we need this for
"when we already have books?"
(both laugh)
("On Your Toes")
- My kid's favorite thing to
eat is gonna be vegetables.
- They're gonna be like,
"Mom, we're out of asparagus again."
And I'll be like, "You
kids and your asparagus."
- I'm not gonna be one of those
schedule obsessed parents.
I'm gonna be chill.
And my kids are gonna appreciate it.
- I am never gonna say that I can't go out
after 10 pm because I got kids.
- Yeah, that's what Red Bull
and baby sitters are for.
- Yes!
- I'll always be on time, just like now.
- And when my kids are tired,
they'll go to bed.
It's not rocket science.
- There's no reason why having a baby
should prevent you from doing Cross Fit.
- When my kid says, "Watch, mommy."
I'm gonna watch every single time.
- Oh absolutely.
I hate it when people are
like, "Just a minute, honey."
That's your kid.
- I will never leave the house
looking less than put together.
- I'm not even gonna own
a pair of sweat pants.
(both laugh)
- Awww.
- I miss being an expert.
("On Your Toes")